THREE GOOD. GREAT I MEAN I'M
THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
VIEWTIFUL OUT HERE THIS TIME OF
YEAR. THE PAST NINE MONTHS MY
ADMINISTRATION HAS INITIATED
THE SINGLE GREATEST
MOBILIZATION. IN U. S. HISTORY
PIONEERING DEVELOPING AND
MANUFACTURING THERAPIES AND
VACCINES IN RECORD TIME-
NUMBERS LIKE NOBODY'S SEEN
BEFORE. NO MEDICAL BREAKTHROUGH
OF THIS SCOPE AND MAGNITUDE HAS
EVER BEEN ACHIEVED THIS RAPIDLY
THIS QUICKLY AND WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF IT AND HAD TREMENDOUS
HELP FROM THE MILITARY.
GENERALS ADMIRALS AND MANY OF
THE GREAT PEOPLE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE OPERATION WARP SPEED IS
UNEQUALED AND UNRIVALLED
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD AND
LEADERS OF OTHER COUNTRIES OF
CALLED ME TO CONGRATULATE. US
ON WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
AND WHICH HELPED. MANY
COUNTRIES WITH THE VENTILATORS
AND ALL OF THE PROBLEMS THEY
WERE HAVING AND I'D LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE EVERYONE INVOLVED
IN THIS EFFORT. IT'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE EFFORT AS A RESULT
OF OPERATION WARP SPEED. VISOR
ANNOUNCED ON MONDAY THAT ITS
CHINA VIRUS VACCINE IS MORE
THAN 90% EFFECTIVE. THIS FAR
EXCEEDS ANY AND ALL
EXPECTATIONS NOBODY THOUGHT
THEY GET TO THAT LEVEL. AND WE
HAVE OTHERS COMING WHICH WE
THINK WILL BE AT THE CORE LEVEL
MAY BE MORE OF THAT'S POSSIBLE.
IN JULY MY ADMINISTRATION
REACHED AN AGREEMENT WITH
VERIZON TO PROVIDE. ONE POINT
NINE FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. TO
SUPPORT THE MASS MANUFACTURING
AND DISTRIBUTION OF ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOSES. WITH THE OPTION
TO PURCHASE A TOTAL OF SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
SHORTLY THEREAFTER. OUR
INVESTMENT WILL MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR THE VACCINE TO BE
PROVIDED BY PFIZER FREE OF
CHARGE. FIZER SAID IT WASN'T
PART OF WHAT SPEED BUT THAT
TURNED OUT TO BE A- UNFORTUNATE
MISREPRESENTATION THEY ARE
PART. THAT'S WHY WE GAVE THEM
THE ONE POINT NINE FIVE
MILLION. BILLION DOLLARS AND-
IT WAS AN UNFORTUNATE MISTAKE
THAT THEY MADE WHEN THEY SAID
THAT WE WILL WORK TO SECURE AN
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION.
WHICH SHOULD BE COMING DOWN
EXTREMELY SOON AND BY
REGISTRATION WILL THEN
COORDINATE THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THE VACCINE. AND IT WILL BE
APPROVED I THINK AGAIN IT WILL
BE APPROVED VERY VERY QUICKLY
WE HELP. THE AVERAGE OF ELEMENT
TIMELINE FOR THE VACCINE
INCLUDING CLINICAL TESTS AND
MANY FACTION CAN TAKE EIGHT TO
TWELVE YEARS THROUGH OPERATION
WARP SPEED WE'RE DOING IT IN
LESS THAN ONE YEAR. IF YOU HAD
A DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATION WITH
DIFFERENT PEOPLE WHAT WE'VE
DONE WOULD HAVE TAKEN IN MY
OPINION THREE EACH FOR FIVE
YEARS IT WOULD HAVE. BEEN IN
THE FTA FOREVER. THIS IS FIVE
TIMES FASTER THAN THE FASTEST
PRIOR VACCINE DEVELOPMENT IN
HISTORY FIVE TIMES FASTER SAID
AGAIN FIVE TIMES FASTER. NOBODY
CAN BELIEVE IT ACTUALLY THREE
OTHER VACCINES ARE ALSO IN THE
FINAL STAGES OF TRIAL THEY'LL
ARRIVE WITHIN A FEW WEEKS. AND
THEY WILL ALSO BE MASS PRODUCED
AND THE DELIVERY WILL BE VERY
RAPID WERE. READY TO GO THE
VACCINE WILL BE. DISTRIBUTED TO
FRONTLINE WORKERS THE ELDERLY
AND HIGH RISK AMERICANS
IMMEDIATELY. WILL BE VERY- A
MATTER OF WEEKS GET OUT VERY
VERY MUCH AHEAD OF SCHEDULE ANY
SCHEDULE THAT I SAID WE'RE
GOING TO BE FAR. AHEAD OF THAT.
WE KNOW THAT THIS VIRUS
PRIMARILY TARGETS OLDER
POPULATIONS AND THOSE WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS
WELL OVER NINETY NINE POINT 98%
OF THOSE UNDER THE AGE OF FIFTY
MAKE A FULL. AND QUICK
RECOVERY. BY GIVING THE VACCINE
TO HIGH RISK INDIVIDUALS RIGHT
AWAY WILL DRAMATICALLY REDUCE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS-
CASE LEVELS ARE HIGH BUT A LOT
OF THE CASE LEVELS ARE HIGH
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT. WE
HAVE THE BEST TESTING PROGRAM
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD WE'VE
DEVELOPED THE MOST AND THE BEST
TEST AND RETEST FAR MORE THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTRY SO IT SHOWS
OBVIOUSLY. MORE CASES. BY
VACCINATING THE ELDERLY IN THE
HIGH RISK WE WILL. EFFECTIVELY
END THIS PHASE OF THE PANDEMIC
IT ALLOWS SENIORS TO RECLAIM
THEIR GOLDEN YEARS THE GOLDEN
YEARS OF THEIR LIVES WHICH IS
SO INCREDIBLE. AND IT'S ABOUT
TIME THAT THEY CAN HAVE THOSE
GOLDEN YEARS AGAIN THIS PROCESS
IS STARTING. RIGHT AWAY
MILLIONS OF DOSES WILL SOON BE
GOING OUT THE DOOR. THEY'RE
ALREADY. WAITING FOR THAT FINAL
APPROVAL AS SOON AS APRIL THE
VACCINE WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
THE ENTIRE GENERAL POPULATION.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF PLACES
LIKE NEW YORK STATE WHERE FOR
POLITICAL REASONS THE GOVERNOR-
DECIDED THEY SAY AND CAN I
DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD
POLITICALLY I THINK IT'S VERY
BAD FROM A HEALTH STANDPOINT
BUT- HE WANTS TO TAKE HIS TIME
OF THE VACCINE HE DOESN'T.
TRUST WHERE THE VACCINES COMING
FROM THESE ARE COMING FROM THE
GREATEST- COMPANIES ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD GREATEST LABS IN THE
WORLD. BUT HE DOESN'T TRUST THE
FACT THAT IT'S THIS WHITE HOUSE
THIS ADMINISTRATION SO WE WON'T
BE DELIVERING IT TO NEW YORK
UNTIL WE HAVE AUTHORIZATION TO
DO SO AND THAT PAINS ME TO SAY
THAT. THIS IS A VERY SUCCESSFUL
AMAZING VACCINE AT 90% AND
MORE. BUT SO THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR CUOMO WILL HAVE TO LET
US KNOW WHEN HE'S READY FOR IT
OTHERWISE WE CAN'T WE CAN'T BE
IN DELIVERING IT TO A STATE.
THAT WILL BE GIVING IT TO ITS
PEOPLE FOR IMMEDIATELY. AND I
KNOW MANY I KNOW THE PEOPLE OF
NEW YORK VERY WELL I KNOW THEY
WANTED SO THE GOVERNOR WILL LET
US KNOW WHEN HE'S READY. HE'S
HAD SOME VERY BAD EDITORIALS.
RECENTLY ABOUT THIS THE
STATEMENT AND WHAT'S HAPPENED
WITH RESPECT TO NURSING HOMES
AND HIS HANDLING OF. NURSING
HOMES AND I HOPE HE DOESN'T
HANDLE THIS AS BADLY AS IS
HANDLED THE NURSING HOMES. BUT
WE'RE READY DIDN'T PROVIDE IT
AS SOON AS- THEY LET US KNOW
THAT THEY'LL ACTUALLY USE IT.
AND AGAIN IT'S A VERY SAFE AND
A GREAT VACCINE. ALREADY WE
HAVE AMONG THE LOWEST CASE
FIDELITY RATES. ARE COUNTRY
ANY. WHERE IN THE WORLD THE
ENTIRE WORLD. AND WE PERFORM
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER THAN OUR
PEER COUNTRIES. AS FAR AS
THERAPEUTICS ARE CONCERNED BY
ADMINISTRATION'S ALSO MADE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS AND
THERAPIES THAT HAVE. HELPED
REDUCE THE MORTALITY RATE BY
85% THAT'S TO ME ONE OF THE
MOST EXCITING. THINGS SENATE
CREDIBLE SOME OF THE- ANTIBODY
VACCINES AND OTHERS THAT HAVE
COME OUT IN A REALLY HELP
PEOPLE EIGHTY FIVE PERCENT.
LAST MONTH THE FDA APPROVED REP
DISAPPEAR. AND WHICH SECURED
ENOUGH FROM DISAPPEAR TO TREAT
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. PATIENTS MY
ADMINISTRATION FINALIZED AN
AGREEMENT WITH ELI LILLY. TO
PURCHASE THE FIRST DOSES OF
THEIR ANTIBODY THERAPY WHICH
SHOWS AMAZING RESULTS THIS TRIP
AND WILL BE AVAILABLE
COMPLETELY FREE OF COST TO
PATIENTS FIVE THOUSAND UNITS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN SHIPPED. AND
MANY MORE GOING OUT THE DOOR AS
WE SPEAK WILL ALSO REACH AN
AGREEMENT WITH ASTRAZENECA FOR
THE LARGE SCALE MANUFACTURING
OF THEIR ANTIBODY TREATMENT.
WHICH IS EXCELLENT WE EXPECT TO
ISSUE EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATIONS FOR A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL TREATMENTS. IN THE
NEAR FUTURE TREMENDOUS. PROMISE
BUT REMEMBER THE 85% NUMBER
THAT'S AN INCREDIBLE.
INCREDIBLE NUMBER BUT WE HAVE
SOME TREMENDOUSLY PROMISING
DRUGS ONLINE AND READY TO COME
OUT. WE HAVE ENSURED THAT OUR
FRONT LINE WORKERS HAVE ALL THE
TOOLS THEY NEED MY
ADMINISTRATION'S INVOKED THE
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT AND
RELATED AUTHORITIES OVER ONE
HUNDRED TIMES. AND I'VE MADE A
HISTORIC INVESTMENT INTO OUR
INDUSTRIAL BASE ALL STATE'S IT
REQUESTED PPA FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE RECEIVED THE PP
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY UPON
REQUEST. EVERY AMERICAN WHO
NEEDED A VENTILATOR HAS HAD
ACCESS TO A VENTILATOR THINK OF
THAT. VERY COMPLICATED PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT VERY EXPENSIVE. AND
WE HAVEN'T HAD ONE PERSON IN
THIS WHOLE COUNTRY THAT HAS
REQUESTED A NEEDED A VENTILATOR
THAT HASN'T HAD IT. EVERY
SINGLE REQUEST HAS BEEN
IMMEDIATELY FILLED SO THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS A GREAT JOB
AND NOW WE'RE HELPING THE REST
OF THE WORLD WITH VENTILATORS
BECAUSE IT'S VERY HARD THING
WE'RE PRODUCING ON THOUSANDS OF
THOUSANDS OF VENTILATORS A
MONTH. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS TWENTY TWO THOUSAND BEDS
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE FOR
STATES AND JURISDICTIONS THAT
NEED ADDITIONAL CAPACITY. BUT
WE THINK THAT IT'S GOING TO
START GOING DOWN POSSIBLY. VERY
QUICKLY WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS
BUT WITH THE VACCINE EAGLES
YOU'LL SEE NUMBERS- GOING DOWN-
WITHIN A MATTER OF MONTHS AND
THEY'LL GO DOWN VERY RAPIDLY AS
WE CONTINUE TO COMBAT THE VIRUS
OUR ECONOMY. IS REBOUNDING FAR
BEYOND ANY EXPECTATIONS I SEE
THE STOCK MARKET'S UP ALMOST
FOUR HUNDRED POINTS TODAY AGAIN
AND- IT'S READY TO BREAK THE
ALL TIME RECORD OUR JOBS
RECORDS ARE. INCREDIBLE THE JOB
NUMBERS ARE INCREDIBLE IN THE
LAST SIX MONTHS WE'VE CREATED
OVER THIRTEEN MILLION JOBS AND
SLASH THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE. BY
MORE THAN HALF. LAST QUARTER WE
WENT IS THE FASTEST ECONOMIC
GROWTH EVER RECORDED IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY THIRTY
THREE POINT 1% IT'S A NUMBER
THAT. IS MORE THAN DOUBLE OUR
HIGHEST THAT WAS IN NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO. AND WE'VE MORE THAN
DOUBLED IN THE UNITED STATES
EXPERIENCES SMALLEST ECONOMIC
CONTRACTION. AND THE MOST RAPID
ECONOMIC RECOVERY OF ANY MAJOR
WESTERN NATION. WE WENT DOWN
LESS AND WE WENT UP MORE. WHICH
IS QUITE. A COMBINATION OF
FACTS. WEALTHY AMERICANS HAVE
GONE BACK TO WORK AND TO SCHOOL
WE CONTINUE TO SPARE NO EXPENSE
TO PROTECT THE ELDERLY AND THE
VULNERABLE. ACCORDING TO SOME
ESTIMATES SAY NATIONAL LOCKED
DOWN BECAUSE FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS A DAY. AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS EVERY SINGLE
DAY. IDEALLY WE WON'T GO TO A
LOCKDOWN I WILL NOT GO THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT BE
GOING TO A LOCKED OUT HOPEFULLY
THE- THE- WHATEVER HAPPENS IN
THE FUTURE WHO KNOWS WHICH
ADMINISTRATION WILL BE IUESS
TIME WILL TELL BUT- I CAN TELL
YOU THIS ADMINISTRATION WILL
NOT GO TO A LOCKDOWN. IT WON'T.
BE NECESSITY LOCKDOWNS COST
LIVES. AND THEY COST A LOT OF
PROBLEMS THE CURE. CAN NOT BE.
YOU GOTTA REMEMBER CANNOT BE
WORSE THAN THE PROBLEM ITSELF
AND I'VE SAID IT MANY TIMES.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENS DURING A LOCK DOWN I
JUST SAID VERY LOUDLY IT'S
HORRIBLE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
DRUGS ALCOHOL. DEPRESSION LOSS
OF JOBS. BUSINESS CLOSURES IT'S
A TERRIBLE THING SO- THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT GO
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES WILL
NOT GO TO A LOT DOWN BUT WILL
BE VERY VIGILANT VERY CAREFUL.
WE UNDERSTAND THE DISEASE AND
SAY. IT'S A COMPLICATED DISEASE
BUT WE UNDERSTAND IT VERY WELL.
WE ASK ALL AMERICANS TO REMAIN
VIGILANT ESPECIALLY AS THE
WEATHER GETS COLDER IT BECOMES
MORE DIFFICULT TO GO OUTSIDE
AND TO HAVE OUTSIDE GATHERINGS.
AND THAT WITH THAT I JUST WANT
TO ASK- SOME VERY TALENTED
PEOPLE TO COME UP AND SAY A FEW
WORDS. GENERAL PERNA AND DR
SLOWEY HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE- THE
GENERAL IS REALLY GETTING
STARTED RIGHT NOW BUT HE'S
REALLY WHAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HE STARTED.
PUTTING THIS ALL TOGETHER SIX
MONTHS AGO WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE SOME REAL ACTION SO GENERAL
MAYBE I'LL START IT OFF. AND
THE DOCTOR YOU'LL GO RIGHT
AFTER THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I'M GOING TO FINISH IT OFF
WITH MIKE PENCE. OKAY THANK YOU
PLEASE. THANK YOU SURE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT HI EVERYBODY
SO OPERATIONAL SPEEDS MISSION
IS TO ENABLE AND ACCELERATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF VACCINES AND
THERAPEUTIC TO HAVE CONTROLLED
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
SAVE LIVES. ON MAY FIFTEENTH
ALMOST SIX MONTHS AGO TO THE
DAY. WE STATED THE GOAL OF THE
OPERATION WHICH WAS TO HAVE
VACCINES AND THERAPEUTICS
AVAILABLE AND APPROVED FOR USE
IN THE U. S. POPULATION. BY THE
END OF THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY.
WE SAID THEN THAT WHY VERY
CHALLENGING. THE GOAL WAS
CREDIBLE AND THEREFORE. WAS
WORTH TRYING WITH. THE BEST OUR
BEST TO ACHIEVE IT. TWO THEY
WERE ALMOST SIX MONTHS LATER
AND I THINK WE CAN SAY THAT
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE. AND WHY WE ARE NOT THERE
YET. WE ARE. CLOSE TO THE
OBJECTIVE. LET ME SHARE WITH
YOU SOME FACTS. IF I LOOK AT
THE VACCINE SIDE WAS SET TO THE
PORTFOLIO OF SIX VACCINES USING
THREE DIFFERENT PLATFORM
TECHNOLOGIES AND WE ELECTED TO
HAVE TWO VACCINES FROM EACH.
PLATFORM TECHNOLOGY. FIRST
PLATFORM IS WHAT'S CALLED
MESSENGER RNA INTO VACCINES
USING THAT PLATFORM. WHERE IN
THE PORTFOLIO ONE BY FIZER AND
ONE BY A MOTHER IN THE SECOND
PLATFORMS USING. WHAT'S CALLED
LIVE VIRAL VECTORS AND WE HAD
ONE VACCINE FROM J. AND J. AND
ONE VACCINE FROM ASTRAZENECA
THE SENATE GOV IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OXFORD UNIVERSITY AND THE
THIRD PLATFORM. WAS THE
RECOMBINANT PROTEIN PLATFORM
WITH ONE VACCINES FROM A BUY
THE COMPANY IN THE U. S.
BECAUSE NOVAVAX. AND ANOTHER
ONE FROM A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
SANOFI AND GLAXOSMITHKLINE.
THESE VACCINES ARE NOW SIX
VACCINES ARE OLD IN THE
CLINICAL DEVELOPMENT STAGES.
AND FOUR OF THEM ARE IN PHASE
THREE TRIALS AND OF THE FOUR
THAT ARE IN PHASE THREE TRIALS.
TO HAVE EFFECTIVELY COMPLETED
ENROLLMENT IN THE PHASE THREE
TRIAL AND ONE OF THE TWO HAS
ANNOUNCED ON MONDAY. TWO I
THINK- THRILLING INFORMATION
THAT THEY HAD 90% EFFICACY THAT
WAS THE FIZER VACCINE.
DEMONSTRATING THAT VACCINATION
IS POSSIBLE AGAINST COVID
NINETEEN THAT THE KIND OF
CHOICES WE HAVE MADE IN TERMS
OF THE INSURGENTS. THAT WAS
EFFECTIVE- AND MAY THIS
OPTIMISTIC THAT ALL VACCINE-
MAY ALSO BE EFFECTIVE. ON
WEDNESDAY SAME WEEK. JUSTICE
WEDNESDAY MORE THEY'RE NOT THE
OTHER COMPANY WITH THE VACCINE
USING SIMILAR PLATFORM
TECHNOLOGY MESSENGER RNA
ANNOUNCES THEY HAVE ACHIEVED A
NUMBER OF CASES IN THERE
TRYING. TO ALLOW FOR FIRST
INTERNET IS AND I WOULD EXPECT
THAT SHORTLY PROBABLY NEXT WEEK
WE MAY HEAR WHAT I HOPE TO BE
ANOTHER VERY GOOD INFORMATION
REGARDING. INDICATIONS VACCINE.
THE TWO OTHER VACCINES THAT ARE
IN PHASE THREE TRIALS THAT ARE
USING THE LIVE VICTOR- PLATFORM
THE J. AND J. VACCINE AND
ASTRAZENECA. VACCINE RECRUITED
ALREADY IF TIMES SERBS IN THE
TRYING I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THE
SUPPORT AND TO IN AS MANY
AMERICANS. AS POSSIBLE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO VOLUNTEER TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS CLINICAL
TRIALS. AS THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
WE ARE ABLE TO ACHIEVE A
DEMONSTRATION OF THE SAFETY AND
THE EFFICACY OF THESE VACCINES.
THE LAST TWO VACCINES THE
PROPANE RECOMBINANT PROTEIN
VACCINES ARE PLANNED TO START
THEIR PHASE THREE TRIALS WITHIN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS. AND WHILE
WE ARE DEVELOPING THESE VACCINE
WE HAVEN'T ONLY LOOKED AT THE
CLINICAL DEVELOPMENT OF COURSE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE THE SPONSORS
FOR THE VACCINE WE ALSO
INVESTED VERY SIGNIFICANTLY. IN
THE MANUFACTURING. OF THESE
VACCINE IN SUCH A WAY AS TO
WHEN WE HAVE THE CLINICAL.
EFFICACY DEMONSTRATION WITH
THESE VACCINES WE WOULD ALSO
HAVE VACCINE DOES IS TO BE ABLE
TO IMMUNIZE. THE US POPULATION.
SO THE TWO VACCINES THAT. ARE
COMPLETING THE PHASE THREE
TRIAL ARE LIKELY TO BE FILING.
THEIR FIRES WITH THE FDA FOR A
POTENTIAL EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION WITHIN THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS. AND HOPEFULLY IF
APPROVED THEY COULD BE. USED
FOR IMMUNIZATION IN THE U. S.
POPULATION IN THE MONTH OF
DECEMBER AND WE HAVE. WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE ENOUGH VACCINE
THOSE IS AVAILABLE FOR USE
INDIA'S POPULATION THREE
MINUTES ABOUT TWENTY MILLION
INDIVIDUALS IN THE MONTH OF
DECEMBER. AND ANOTHER TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY MILLION PER
MONTH ON AN ONGOING BASIS FROM
THERE ON. AND AS OF THE MONTH
OF FEBRUARY OR MARCH IF WE HAVE
MORE VACCINES APPROVED SUCH AS
A LIVE VECTORED VACCINE. WE MAY
BE ABLE TO IMMUNIZE A LARGE
NUMBER OF AMERICANS- YEAH ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AFTER MONTHS.
OPERATION WOLFSPEED DIDN'T ONLY
FOCUS ON VACCINES. WE ALSO
LOOKED AT THERAPEUTICS AND WE
HAVE WORKED WITH A NUMBER OF
COMPANIES DEVELOPING MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES IN PARTICULAR THAT
ARE ABLE TO NEUTRALIZE THE
VIRUS. AS MISTER PRESIDENT SAID
WE HAVE ANNOUNCED PARTNERSHIPS
WITH A LADY WITH REGENERON AND
WITH ASTRAZENECA. AND ON MONDAY
LADIES ONE ACCOUNTABILITY WAS
GRANTED EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION TO TREAT THE
PATIENTS THAT ARE INFECTED AND
THAT'S RISK OF HOSPITALIZATION.
REGENERON ANTIBODIES. I HAVE
BEEN FILED FOR EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION WHICH IS
CURRENTLY UNDER REVIEW AND IS
POTENTIALLY- YEAH REACHING
APPROVAL WITHIN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS. FINALLY ASTRAZENECA JUST
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS HAS
RECEIVED THE GREEN LIGHT TO
START TWO LARGE PHASE THREE
TRIALS WITH THEIR- MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES SUPPORTED BY
OPERATIONAL MORE SPEED. TO
PREVENT- THE ACQUISITION OF
COVID NINETEEN DISEASE IN VERY
FRAIL. SUBJECTS OR IN VERY HIGH
RISK SUBJECTS AS A PROTECTIVE-
ATTENTIVE TO VACCINE. SO
POTENTIALLY TO VACCINES AND TWO
THERAPEUTICS MAY BE GRANTED AN
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION
BEFORE THE END OF THIS YEAR. I
THINK IT'S A REMARKABLE
ACHIEVEMENT WITHIN A PERIOD OF
SIX TO SEVEN MONTHS. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
PROGRESS HAS BEEN ACHIEVED
WITHOUT ANY POLITICAL
INTERFERENCE. I SAID IT MANY
TIMES. AND AT EVERY STEP HAS
BEEN AND IS BEING JUDGED BY
INDEPENDENT EXPERT BODIES.
WHETHER IT'S WHEN THE FDA
GRANTS THE GREEN LIGHT TO GO
INTO CLINICAL TRIALS OR WHETHER
WHEN THE DATA SAFETY MONITORING
BOARDS. REVIEW THE SAFETY OF
THE CITY'S ON AN ONGOING BASIS
AND SOMETIMES PUT THEM ON HOLD
AS- I'M SURE YOU HAVE WITNESSED
WITH THE- ASTRAZENECA VACCINE
FOR INSTANCE. AND THE SAME DATA
SAFETY MONITORING BOARDS ARE
THE INDEPENDENT BOARDS OF
EXPERTS THAT ANALYZE THE
EFFICACY OF THE VACCINES AND
THE SAFETY OF THE VACCINES AND
TELL THE COMPANIES. WHETHER
THEY SHOULD PROGRESS WITH THE
FILING OF EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION. OR OR NOT SO
IT'S NOT THE COMPANIES. IT'S
NOT OPERATIONAL SPEED IT'S NOT
THE US GOVERNMENT IT IS
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS. THAT
ASSESS THE SAFETY AND EFFICACY
OF THE VACCINES THAT ARE BEING
TESTED. AND WHEN THE FDA WOULD
REVIEW THESE VACCINES AND
DISTRIBUTE SIX. THEY WILL ALSO
HAVE THE ADVICE. TAKE ADVICE
FROM BOARDS ONE OF THEM IS
CALLED THE VERY FACT THAT IS
THE ADVISORY BOARD TO THE FDA
FOR VACCINE REVIEWS ON WHAT
AFTER REVIEW OF THE OF THE OF
THE DATA TRANSPARENTLY
UNAVAILABLE TO EVERYBODY TO
LOOK INTO. BEFORE THE FDA THEN
MAKE ITS DECISION TO EITHER
AUTORIZA VACCINE. OR NOT
AUTHORIZED. ON THAT BASIS I
PERSONALLY FEEL VERY
COMFORTABLE TO SAY. THAT THE
VACCINES AND THERAPEUTICS THAT
WE HAVE HAVE DEVELOPED AND
ACCELERATES. WE'LL BE JUDGED
INDEPENDENTLY AND IF APPROVED
SHOULD BE USED BY OLD IN THE
POPULATION. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
EXPLANATION IS LIKELY TO BE THE
CORNERSTONE AMONG ALL THE ALL
OTHER MEASURES THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE. TO HELP US REALLY CONTROL
THIS PANDEMIC. I WOULD NOT PASS
TO MY CORY EITHER GENERAL PERNA
WHO WILL TELL YOU MORE ABOUT
THE SUPPORT THAT THE OPERATION
HAS PROVIDED TO MANUFACTURING
OF THE VACCINE AND ALSO TO
THEIR DISTRIBUTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO CONTINUE
SERVICE OF OUR GREAT NATION IS
A COLD LEADER WITH DOCTOR
MONTHS OF SLOWLY ON THIS
MISSION. LET ME START BY
EMPHASIZING FOR ME. WHAT IS
OPERATIONAL WAR SPEED ABOUT IT
IS ABOUT SAVING LIVES IN IT IS
A HERCULEAN TASK- THAT THE
PRESIDENT PUT US ON MANY MONTHS
AGO- AND AS DR SLOUGH JUST LAID
OUT WE ARE MAKING STEADY
PROGRESS- AND WE ARE READY TO
EXECUTE. THROUGH THE WHOLE OF
AMERICAN APPROACH WE HAVE
LEVERAGE THE BEST OF NATION IN
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. LOCAL
STATE'S INDUSTRY AND ACADEMIA
TO EXPAND THE CAPACITY AND
CAPABILITY TO ACHIEVE OUR
MISSION. IT IS BEEN POWERFUL WE
HAVE CAPITALIZED ON THE BEST
CONTRACTING LOGISTICS AND
PLANNING EXPERTS AVAILABLE TO
SYNCHRONIZE AND INTEGRATE ALL
PHASES OF THE OPERATION FROM
DEVELOPMENTS OF THE VACCINE
MANUFACTURING- THE VACCINE AND
FINALLY DISTRIBUTION OF THE
VACCINE. SIX MONTHS AGO THE
CAPACITY DID NOT EXIST IN OUR
NATION'S PHARMACEUTICAL
PRODUCTION BASE WE WENT TO WORK
BUILDING BRICK AND MORTAR
MANUFACTURING FACILITIES
BRINGING IN THE RIGHT
SPECIALIZED MACHINERY AND
EQUIPMENT AND PRIORITIZING
SUPPLY CHAIN. YOUR REAL THROUGH
THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT.
TODAY WE EXPECT TO HAVE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOSES IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING E. WAY AND WE WILL
DISTRIBUTE THEM AS SOON AS THE
FDA. APPLIES THE E. WAY WE WILL
DO THAT WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS OF THE WAY WE ARE
HARNESSING THE STRENGTH OF
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRY AND THE
EXISTING VACCINE DELIVERY
CAPABILITIES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
OUR NATION DESERVES THIS
VACCINE WILL BE ALLOCATED PRO
RATA BY POPULATION SO THAT WE
ENSURE A FAIR AND EQUITABLE
ACROSS. WE NEED THE STATE'S WHO
ARE PART OF THE PLANNING TO
ACCEPT THE VACCINE. WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY ALONG WITH THE
CDC THE SIXTY FOUR
JURISDICTIONS AND STATES TO
ENSURE VACCINE CAN SAFELY AND
QUICKLY GET TO THOSE WHO NEED
IT FIRST. AND THEN WE HAVE
PLANS TO ENSURE THAT IT SPREADS
EXPONENTIALLY ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY AND THAT NO PLACE IS
LEFT WITHOUT A VACCINE AT THE
END OF THE DAY OUR SUCCESS IS
GOING TO BE JUDGED BY THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE VACCINE AS
SHOTS GO IN ARMS. IT IS THE
PARTNERSHIPS WE HAVE FORMED
WITH THE PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES LIKE PFIZER AND
MADONNA. DISTRIBUTION COMPANIES
LIKE MCKESSON FED EX AND UPS
AND PHARMACIES LIKE CVS AND
WALGREENS THAT HAVE AGREED. TO
DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY THE THINK
HOW CAN WE GET THIS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE MOST
RAPID AN EXPEDITION EXPEDITION
THIS WAY. WE WILL BE SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE OF THIS ALL OF AMERICA
APPROACH THIS COLLABORATION
THIS EFFORT THAT EVERYBODY IS
LEADING TOWARDS. I WILL END
WHERE I STARTED THIS IS ABOUT
SAVING LIVES. THE LIVES OF THE
GREAT AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WE
WILL NOT REST UNTIL WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL AND THAT WE HAVE
YOUR REVERSIBLE MOMENTUM TO
RETURNING OUR NATION BACK TO
NORMAL. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU GENERAL VERY MUCH
GREAT JOB. ALEX PLACE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT FOR PROVIDING
THE LEADERSHIP THAT'S GOTTEN US
WHERE WE ARE TODAY. THE SUCCESS
THAT OPERATION WARP SPEED IS
REALIZED SO FAR HAS BEEN MADE
POSSIBLE ONLY ■BECAUSE OF THE
BOLD VISION YOU ANNOUNCED NOT
EVEN SIX MONTHS AGO RIGHT HERE
IN THE ROSE GARDEN. TO
HIGHLIGHT THREE OF THE
REMARKABLE ACCOMPLISHMENTS WE
SEE JUST THIS WEEK FIRST FIZER
ANNOUNCED VERY PROMISING DOUBT
ON ITS VACCINE CANDIDATE SECOND
EAGLE ON THE SECOND THE FDA
AUTHORIZED WE HAVE BEGUN TO
DISTRIBUTE AND ADMINISTER ELI
LILLY'S MONOCLONAL ANTIBODY TO
HELP AMERICANS AT RISK FOR
SERIOUS DISEASE. STAY OUT OF
THE HOSPITAL THIRD ANOTHER
VACCINE COMPANY MADERA
ANNOUNCED THAT IT'S REACHED A
CRITICAL CLINICAL TRIAL
MILESTONE MEETING WE MAY SEE
DOWN FROM THAT WITHIN DAYS.
BACK IN THE SPRING WE WERE TOLD
BY ALL THE EXPERTS AT A VACCINE
WAS A YEAR OR YEAR AND A HALF
AWAY. AND THE ANNOUNCEMENTS I
JUST HIGHLIGHTED WOULD HAVE
BEEN UNTHINKABLE. THE PRESIDENT
SAID THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE. AND
THANKS TO THE SUPPORT HE'S
PROVIDED WE'RE NOW ON TRACK TO
DELIVER SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
VACCINE TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
THIS YEAR. AS I WORK WITH THE
PRESIDENT TO ASSEMBLE THIS TEAM
AND ORGANIZE THIS EFFORT HIS
SUPPORT WAS INDISPENSABLE AT
EACH STEP OF THE WAY. WE WENT
OUT AND FOUND THE VERY BEST
PEOPLE ON THE PLANET TO DO THE
JOB WHO YOU JUST TALKED WITH.
DOCTOR SLOUGH WITH THE WORLD'S
MOST SUCCESSFUL VACCINE
DEVELOPER. GENERAL PURDAH ONE
OF THE WORLD'S MOST QUALIFIED
LOGISTICS LEADERS. WHEN I FIRST
TALKED TO DOCTOR SLOUGH IN
GENERAL PERNA ABOUT OUR GOALS
AND RECRUITED THEM TO THIS
EFFORT. WE DREAMED OF BEING AT
THE POINT WE'RE AT TODAY. ON
TRACK TO ACHIEVE THE INCREDIBLY
AMBITIOUS GOAL WE SET TOGETHER.
THE PRESIDENT GAVE US THE FULL
FINANCIAL SUPPORT WE NEEDED.
ENABLING US TO INVEST MORE THAN
TEN BILLION DOLLARS TO D. RISK
VACCINE COMPANIES DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS. AND MANUFACTURE
PRODUCT IN ADVANCE. OUR
COMPLETELY UNPRECEDENTED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT HAS GIVEN US A
COMPREHENSIVE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PLAN FOR DISTRIBUTION AND HELP
EACH UPRATED WARP SPEED VACCINE
MAKER SECURE WHAT THEY NEEDED
FOR MANUFACTURING INCLUDING
PFIZER'S ONGOING. PRODUCTION
THIS WEEK. OPERATION WARP SPEED
HAS ALWAYS HAD ONE GOAL SAVING
LIVES. THE PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN
O. W. S. THE INDEPENDENCE IT
NEEDS TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL AND
ENSURE THAT WE'RE FOLLOWING THE
PROCEDURES THAT AMERICANS
EXPECT FOR ANY MEDICAL PRODUCT
THEY TAKE AT EVERY STEP
ENSURING PATIENT SAFETY HAS
BEEN OUR TOP PRIORITY. THIS
PROCESS HAS BEEN DRIVEN SOLELY
BY SCIENCE AND DATA. SO IT'S A
SHAME THAT SOME ONE EXAMPLE
BEING THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK
HAVE ACTUALLY INJECTED POLITICS
INTO THE PROCESS AND SUGGESTED
THE POSSIBILITY OF
INTENTIONALLY DELAYING ACCESS.
TO AN FDA AUTHORIZED VACCINE
WHICH IS SIMPLY ON
CONSCIONABLE. BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT HAS DELIVERED THE
FULL FUNDING WE NEED THE BEST
PEOPLE ON THE PLANET AND REAL
INDEPENDENCE FOR THIS PROJECT
OPERATION WARP SPEED IS DOING
SOMETHING THAT'S NEVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE IN HISTORY. THIS
SUCCESS MEANS THERE IS LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE TUNNEL. RIGHT
NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO LET OUR
GUARD DOWN WE CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE AMERICANS TO FOLLOW
THE THREE W'S WASH YOUR HANDS
WATCHER DISTANCE WEAR A MASK
WHEN YOU CAN'T WATCH YOUR
DISTANCE. AND AVOID SETTINGS
WHERE YOU CAN'T DO THOSE
THINGS. BECAUSE OF THE
INCREDIBLE AMERICAN SPIRIT
BECAUSE OF A GREAT SCIENTISTS
AND PUBLIC SERVANTS AND
INNOVATORS OF DONE THROUGH
OPERATION WARP SPEED. WE HAVE
SUCH A BRIGHT FUTURE AHEAD OF
US. IF WE CONTINUE TO PROTECT
OURSELVES OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT FUTURE WILL BE
HERE VERY SOON. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FOR MAKING THAT VERY
BRIGHT FUTURE POSSIBLE FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. THANK YOU MIKE
PENCE PLEASE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND ON BEHALF OF THE
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS TASK
FORCE. I WAS GRATEFUL TO JUST
HAVE A FEW MINUTES TODAY TO
COMMEND THE TEAM OF OPERATION
MORE SPEED. IT WAS YOUR VISION
THAT WE COULD HARNESS THE
INGENUITY AND CREATIVITY OF
AMERICA'S GREATEST
PHARMACEUTICAL AND RESEARCH
COMPANIES. TO SPEED IN RECORD
TIME. A VACCINE THAT WOULD SAVE
AMERICAN LIVES HE TOLD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A VACCINE BEFORE THE END
OF THE YEAR AND- SOME SCOFFED
AT THAT TIME TABLE. BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THE TEAM ON OPERATION
WARP SPEED DIDN'T THESE GREAT
RESEARCH COMPANIES DIDN'T AND
AS YOU'VE ARTICULATED HERE MR
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CAN BE COMFORTED WITH
ALL THE NEWS THIS WEEK. THAT
HELP IS ON THE WAY OF THAT
LITERALLY PENDING FDA APPROVAL
OF THE FIZER VACCINE AND
PERHAPS VERY SOON. ANOTHER
VACCINE TO BE SUBMITTED BY
MADURA AND EVEN OTHER COMPANIES
THAT BEFORE THE YEAR IS OUT
WILL BE ABLE TO ADMINISTER
VACCINE TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AS YOU SAID MR
PRESIDENT. BEGINNING WITH THOSE
MOST VULNERABLE BEGINNING WITH
OUR SENIORS ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY BEGINNING WITH OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS AT THE POINT THE
NEED- IT IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
MEDICAL MOBILIZATION THE
GREATEST IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY AND I JOIN YOU IN
COMMENDING THE STEAM. LET ME
ALSO SAY MR PRESIDENT THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS TASK
FORCE WILL BE MEETING WITH OUR
NATION'S GOVERNORS IN OUR
REGULAR CONFERENCE CALL THIS
MONDAY WILL BE REVIEWED WITHIN
THE PROGRESS ON THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A VACCINE OR PLANS FOR
DISTRIBUTION- BUT- WILL ALSO BE
REVIEWING EACH AND EVERY
STATE'S SPECIFIC PLANS FOR
DISTRIBUTING THE VACCINE.
CONTINUE TO URGE GOVERNORS WHO
HAVE THOSE PLANS DEVELOPED AND
PREPARED AND READY FOR
IMMEDIATE IMPLEMENTATION AND
VIOLINIST PRESIDENT AS WE SEE
CASES RISING AROUND THE COUNTRY
AS WE SEE HOSPITALIZATION
STATIONS RISING AROUND THE
COUNTRY- I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WITH THE
NEWS. OF THAT AS WE HAVE DONE
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING- WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO MOVE HEAVEN
AND EARTH TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR FAMILY HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEVEL OF HEALTH CARE THAT WE
WANTED TO ONE OF OUR MEMBERS OF
OUR FAMILY TO HAVE. I SPOKE TO
FEMA TODAY AND AS WE HEARD
REPORTED OUR LAST TASK FORCE
MEETINGS PRESENT WE'RE
RECEIVING REQUESTS FROM STATES
FOR PPA FOR PERSONNEL BUT WE'RE
MEETING ALL OF THOSE REQUESTS
ACCORDING. TO OUR TEAM ON THE
GROUND WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE
THE AT BE ABLE TO MEET THREE.
FOR PP. AND EQUIPMENT BOTH FROM
THE STRATEGIC NATIONAL
STOCKPILE. ALSO FROM THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE NEEDS ARE ALL MEN.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN ALSO BE
CONFIDENT BECAUSE OF THE SYSTEM
THAT YOU ESTABLISH THAT SINCE
THIS PAST JULY WERE ACTUALLY
ABLE TO TRACK. VP GALLONS AND
GLOVES AND NINETY FIVE MASS ON
A HOSPITAL. BY HOSPITAL BASIS
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO DELIVER
AS YOU SAID MR PRESIDENT. ON
THAT EXTRAORDINARY RECORD IN
AMERICA WHERE NO AMERICAN HAS
EVER REQUIRED. VENTILATORS EVER
BEEN DENIED A VENTILATOR NO
AMERICAN IS EVER REQUIRED AN
ICU BED. IS EVER BEEN DENIED AN
ICU BED. SO THE GOOD NEWS TODAY
THROUGH OPERATION WARP SPEED MR
PRESIDENT'S HELP IS ON THE WAY.
IT'S ON THE WAY RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER. AS ONE OF THE
MEMBERS OF OUR TEST FOR SAID
RECENTLY THE- CAVALRY IS
COMING. WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE
EVERY AMERICAN THAT WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE. THAT
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM HAS THE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT. EQUIPMENT
AND SUPPLIES THAT THEY NEED.
AND WE ALSO MR PRESIDENT AS- AS
WE SEE CASES RISING
PARTICULARLY IN. IN THE
HEARTLAND OF THIS COUNTRY BUT-
IN COMMUNITIES ALL ACROSS
AMERICA WE ENCOURAGE EVERY
AMERICAN AS A SECRETARY DID AS
YOU HAVE. CONTINUED TO.
PRACTICE GOOD HYGIENE WASH YOUR
HANDS. PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING WEAR A MASK WHEN
THAT'S- NOT POSSIBLE WE ALL
HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY WE ALL KNOW
WHAT TO DO. CHECK THE
VULNERABLE. TO LOOK AFTER OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR NEIGHBORS AND
FRIENDS AND WE ENCOURAGE. EVERY
AMERICAN. WITH ALL THE GOOD
NEWS THIS WEEK. A TO CONTINUE
TO BE PERSISTENT AND PUTTING.
THE HEALTH OF YOURSELF YOUR
FAMILY YOUR NEIGHBORS. CO
WORKERS AND FRIENDS FIRST AND-
AND WE'LL GET THROUGH THIS. AND
WE'LL GET THROUGH THIS
TOGETHER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. AND THANK YOU
EVERYBODY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.